Transcriptor: Maria Pereyra
Revisor: Silvina Katz
"La literatura juvenil es basura",
"Qué lástima que recomiendes
tantos libros juveniles,
esos no sirven para nada",
o, mi favorito,
"¿Cuándo vas a leer libros de verdad
y vas a dejar de leer esa basura juvenil?"
Estos son algunos de los muchos
comentarios que me han llegado
a lo largo de los años que llevo
haciendo videos sobre libros
en Internet.
Por lo general elijo no responderlos,
pero sí me he quedado con las ganas
de responder y dar una cátedra
de por qué creo que la literatura
juvenil es importante,
y no como ellos, y muchos otros, aseguran,
basura.
Ustedes podrán pensar que cuando
recibí la invitación para dar esta charla,
yo pensé: "Oh, por fin, es mi oportunidad.
Al fin voy a decir
todo lo que quiero decir".
Pero... No.
La verdad es que hacer esto,
hablar en público,
hasta hace algunos años estaba en la lista
de mis peores pesadillas de la vida.
Soy una persona muy tímida, y aunque
con los años he aprendido un poquito más
a hablar con la gente, a comunicarme
y a hablar en público, todavía me cuesta.
Siempre voy a preferir estar encerrada,
en las paredes de mi cuarto,
grabando videos con una cámara.
Y ni crean, antes eso también me aterraba
por lo mismo que les digo,
que soy bastante tímida.
Pero tengo un lema de vida,
y es que las pasiones siempre
deben vencer tus miedos.
Entonces por eso fue que hace seis años
decidí tomar una cámara
y hablar de los que más me apasiona,
que son los libros.
Entonces llevo todos esos años
hablando de libros en YouTube,
semana tras semana,
y es lo que más me hace feliz.
A estas alturas creo que me he vuelto
una lectora bastante versátil
y leo de todo un poco,
pero sí tengo que decir
que hay un tipo de libros
al que suelo acercarme más
y esos son los libros juveniles.
¿Por qué?
Pues, hay 1001 razones,
pero creo que la principal
es que son los libros que
cambiaron mi vida.
Literalmente cambiaron mi vida,
y la siguen moviendo
y cambiando constantemente.
Como soy muy fan de las historias,
y creo que las historias son maravillosas,
les voy a contar la historia
del primer libro juvenil
que me hizo sentir que no estaba sola
y que me llenó el corazón.
Ese es "Fangirl", de Rainbow Rowell.
Ese libro yo lo leí en el 2013,
y trata de una chica que se llama Cath.
Ella acaba de entrar a la universidad,
y es súper tímida e introvertida,
y pues desde ahí me identifiqué, ¿verdad?
La cosa es que Cath prefiere
quedarse encerrada
en el dormitorio de la universidad
antes que ir a la cafetería a comer,
porque le da pánico enfrentarse
a este mar de gente
que está en la cafetería
y que ella no conoce.
Recuerdo que yo estaba leyendo
reseñas de este libro,
y mucha gente decía:
"La protagonista me pareció
muy poco realista".
Yo dije: "No, porque yo era así".
En la preparatoria y en la universidad
yo era exactamente así.
Si yo no estaba con mis amigos,
no me atrevía a pisar la cafetería.
Yo prefería quedarme en el salón,
dibujando o leyendo... con hambre.
Con mucha hambre,
pero yo no iba a pisar esa cafetería.
Entonces, recuerdo que cuando yo leí
a Cath, a esta protagonista,
lo sentí como un abrazo
para esa Clau del pasado
que tenía tantas inseguridades
y tantos miedos, y pensé:
"Guau, cómo me hubiera gustado leer esto
cuando era una adolescente",
porque me hubiera ayudado
como no tienen una idea.
Pero luego lo pensé, y me di cuenta
de que igual me ayudó,
porque me ayudó a sanar viejas heridas.
Creo que ese fue el primer
acercamiento importante que tuve
al gran impacto que puede causar un libro,
en este caso fue de literatura juvenil.
Lo padre de tener este canal
de libros en YouTube
es que no solamente cuento con
mi experiencia, sino también
con la experiencia de los jóvenes
que ven mis videos.
Muchas veces me he topado con jóvenes
en ferias del libro, o en presentaciones
que me dicen: "Oye, yo leí
este libro por ti
y fue un libro que me hizo sentir
que no estaba solo,
y en el que me pude encontrar".
Cuando les pregunto qué libro fue,
por lo general me responden
con algún título juvenil.
Nunca se me va a olvidar una vez
que un chico de unos 14 o 15 años
se me acercó y me dijo
que él encontró y leyó
"Aristóteles y Dante descubren
los secretos del universo"
por Benjamin Alire Saenz por una
recomendación en mi video,
y que ese libro lo salvó,
porque ese libro le hizo darse cuenta
de que no estaba defectuoso,
de que sus sentimientos eran válidos,
y de que estaba bien que un hombre
quisiera a otro hombre,
porque, créanlo o no,
antes de leer ese libro,
él no había hablado de sus sentimientos
y sus inquietudes con nadie.
Entonces, ese libro le hizo sentir
que no estaba solo,
y que sus sentimientos sí eran válidos.
Siempre que recuerdo su historia
reitero que la literatura
juvenil es importante,
y después de esa me han llegado
miles y miles de historias así.
Antes de continuar, quiero dejar en claro
que la literatura juvenil no es un género
como lo es la fantasía,
o la ciencia ficción, o el terror,
porque muchos la tratan
como género, pero no.
La literatura juvenil
es más una etiqueta que se le da al libro
al momento de su venta.
Es como una categoría
para saber el público objetivo,
y el público joven fue un público
que estuvo ignorado por muchos años.
Yo crecí pensando que solo había
libros infantiles, o libros para adultos,
o clásicos, y me era muy difícil
encontrar un libro que llamara mi atención
porque ni siquiera había una sección
para jóvenes en la librería.
Y es que el fenómeno juvenil tiene
muy pocos años así como tal.
Las editoriales afirman que empezó
a raíz de que se publica
"Bajo la misma estrella" en el 2012.
Este libro ocasionó que se creara
un segmento en el mercado
para la literatura juvenil
por su gran impacto en ventas.
Y no me dejarán mentir, es tiempo
en el que los libros juveniles
siempre están encabezando
las listas de ventas,
y eso es porque los jóvenes
estamos leyendo.
Muchas personas todavía dicen:
"Los jóvenes no leen", pero
solamente tienen que ir, por ejemplo,
a una feria del libro.
Los pasillos están repletos de jóvenes
muy emocionados gritando, saltando,
porque al fin consiguieron
ese libro que tanto buscaban,
o porque al fin consiguieron la firma
de ese autor que tanto querían conocer.
Entonces, yo creo que los jóvenes
de verdad estamos leyendo mucho,
y se refleja en las ventas
de la literatura juvenil.
A mí me gusta incluirme en este grupo
de jóvenes, aunque la realidad
es que ya no soy tan joven.
Pero me gusta repetirme una y otra vez
que sí lo soy, y así yo solita me la creo.
Menciono al público joven porque
una de las razones por las que se
menosprecia más a la literatura juvenil
es que precisamente porque está dirigida
y pensada para jóvenes.
Es como si todo lo que los jóvenes
consumieran fuera basura,
porque obviamente todo
lo que les gusta a los jóvenes no sirve,
y peor si le gusta
a una chica adolescente.
Esto es con sarcasmo, yo no pienso eso,
pero son cosas que he escuchado
con los años y que ya me están cansando.
Yo pienso todo lo contrario,
pienso que los jóvenes
somos inteligentes y apasionados,
y que tenemos cosas importantes que decir,
y que queremos encontrar historias
en las que nuestra voz
se pueda ver reflejada.
Y eso es precisamente lo que nos da
la literatura juvenil.
Los jóvenes no deben ser subestimados;
los autores que escriben juvenil lo saben
y lo demuestran
en los textos que escriben.
En los libros juveniles vemos temas como
política, religión, racismo,
o incluso algunos muy difíciles
y sensibles
como la salud mental,
el suicidio, el acoso sexual,
y también se le da voz a estos grupos
que han sido ignorados durante muchos años
como los es, por ejemplo,
la comunidad LGBT.
Obviamente estoy consciente de que
no todos los libros juveniles son buenos,
o de calidad, yo no soy quién
para juzgarlos.
Pero sé que existen libros
que solo son para entretenimiento
y que no aportan nada.
Pero, ¿adivinen qué?
También hay miles de libros
para adultos que no aportan nada
y que solo son para entretener.
Y ojo, que yo no le veo nada de malo
a leer libros para entretenerse.
Hay muchas personas que dicen:
"¡No, los libros solo deben leerse
para aprender!", okay, es válido.
Pero hay que tener en cuenta que la gente
puede leer lo que quiera,
y que puede leer
por las razones que quiera.
Y no está cool decirle a un joven,
o a un lector nuevo
que lo que está leyendo no cuenta.
Yo creo que deberíamos
hacer todo lo contrario,
deberíamos alegrarnos de que cada vez
haya más gente leyendo,
más jóvenes leyendo, y eso
es gracias a la literatura juvenil.
Lo curioso es que en mi caso no fue así.
Como les dije, yo crecí
en una época remota
en la que los libros juveniles todavía no
estaban tan de moda, no eran populares,
y casi no existían en el mercado,
o por lo menos no había
este segmento destinado hacia ellos.
Entonces, mi camino lector empezó
con libros infantiles,
y de ahí casi instantáneamente
me pasé a clásicos.
En la secundaria y en la preparatoria
leí libros como "La Odisea",
"Las mil y una noches", "Edipo rey",
y me encantaron, me gustaron mucho.
Pero también fue en esa época
que llegó a mi vida "Crepúsculo",
y me volvió loca, me encantó.
El primer amor de mi vida fue
Edward Cullen, el vampiro brillante,
y no me arrepiento de nada.
Recuerdo mucho que en ese tiempo
yo no estaba pensando:
"Deshonra y desgracia. He bajado de nivel.
Venía de leer 'La Odisea'
y ahora leí 'Crepúsculo' ".
No, yo solo estaba pensando
que los libros,
cualquier libro, me hacía feliz,
y leer historias me hacía feliz,
y eso sigue siendo lo que pienso, ¿saben?
Creo que existe esta percepción errónea
de que los libros populares
son de mala calidad,
como si el simple hecho de que estuvieran
de moda los hiciera malos,
y dicen: "Ay, es que los jóvenes
solo leen por moda",
y eso es, aparentemente, horrible,
cuando no debería de ser así,
porque por ejemplo,
yo cuando era chiquita me hubiera
encantado que leer estuviera de moda.
Así no hubiera sido la "rara" que se
quedaba leyendo a la hora del recreo
en vez de salir a jugar.
Y, si leer está de moda, pues,
qué moda tan bonita.
Porque leer debe estar al alcance de todos
y no debe ser solo para un grupo
de intelectuales.
Todos debemos tener al alcance los libros.
A mí me da mucha risa que a veces
me llegan comentarios en plan:
"¡Qué horror que leas tantos
libros de moda!"
y yo no los respondo,
pero si los respondiera, solamente
les preguntaría: "¿Por qué?"
Porque creo que que leer
esté de moda es algo increíble,
qué bonito que cada vez haya más clubes
de lectura en Internet,
qué bonito que cada vez haya más gente
hablando de libros, booktubers,
qué bonito y qué increíble que cada vez
haya más páginas dedicadas a libros
y a sagas.
Me parece maravilloso que en Instagram
existe el hashtag #Bookstagram
y que haya millones de publicaciones.
La semana pasada revisé, y ya iba
en 39 millones de publicaciones
de libros, de fotos de libros.
Creo que eso es maravilloso.
Y también pienso y creo firmemente
que la literatura juvenil es valiosa
y con esta charla no pretendo hacer
que todo el mundo cambie de opinión,
simplemente quería salir a la defensa
de estos libros que me han marcado
a pesar de que no llegaron a mí
en mi adolescencia.
Son libros que siguen impactando
en mi vida, ¿saben?
Porque están llenos de esperanza,
que eso es algo que todos necesitamos,
están llenos de enseñanzas,
y me recuerdan que soy capaz
de sentir a flor de piel,
son los libros que más me emocionan.
Y lo que el arte busca es, precisamente,
evocar sentimientos y emociones.
Entonces nadie me puede negar
que la literatura juvenil es arte.
Los libros juveniles son más
que solo historias para los lectores.
Los libros juveniles responden preguntas
como "¿quién soy?,
¿hacia dónde quiero ir?, ¿en qué creo?,
¿en quién me quiero convertir?",
y me atrevo a decir que algunas
de las historias más valientes
de la actualidad están siendo contadas
en los libros juveniles.
Tomemos por ejemplo
"El odio que das" de Angie Thomas.
Este es un libro que nos muestra
la realidad del racismo en la actualidad.
La protagonista es una chica
que tiene que ver cómo su mejor amigo
es asesinado brutalmente,
sin justificación,
por un policía blanco
solo por su color de piel.
Ella vive esta brutalidad policíaca
y toda su familia y sus seres queridos
le recomiendan que no hable,
que se quede callada,
porque es muy peligroso.
Y ella tiene que decidir, pues,
entre precisamente hacer eso,
quedarse callada, o buscar justicia.
Este libro lleva 153 semanas consecutivas
en la lista de Best Sellers
del New York Times,
y casi siempre está en primer lugar.
¿Por qué?
Porque es una historia importante
y que necesitaba ser contada.
Y de este ejemplo quiero mencionar algo
que la literatura juvenil
hace constantemente.
Habla de temas actuales,
de temas que no podemos encontrar
en libros de años atrás.
Se está concentrando
en los problemas, en las crisis,
en las situaciones que nos estamos
enfrentando en el ahora,
y en lo que nos importa
ahora mismo, en nuestro mundo.
Creo que eso es muy importante.
Además, en la literatura juvenil hay mucha
diversidad y representación.
Escribiendo juvenil hay autores y autoras
de color, de la comunidad LGBT,
con discapacidades,
o con cuerpos que no cumplen con los
estándares de belleza
que se nos ha impuesto
desde todos los tiempos en la sociedad.
Y estas son personas
que crecieron buscando
encontrarse en una obra de ficción,
y no se encontraron.
Entonces ellos ahora están escribiendo
libros contando sus historias,
y eso es muy valioso,
y ya hacía mucha falta.
Además, los libros juveniles
no son solo para jóvenes.
Hay muchos adultos leyendo juvenil.
El año pasado fui a la BookExpo,
que es una feria del libro
muy importante en Nueva York,
y una editora de EE. UU. me dijo
que cada vez había más adultos consumiendo
y comprando literatura juvenil.
Adultos de 35 años, 50 años,
incluso más grandes,
porque son temas tan importantes
y que nos afectan tanto
a todos, no solo a los jóvenes.
Y si algo creo que tienen en común
todas estas historias
en los libros juveniles, no es la trama,
que siempre son muy variadas
e increíbles.
Tampoco es, por ejemplo, la edad
de los personajes protagonistas,
que por lo general varía
entre los 15 y 20 años.
No.
Lo que yo creo que estas historias
tienen en común es
que provocan cambios irreversibles
en la vida de los jóvenes que los leen.
Son libros que nos mueven
y nos tocan en lo más profundo,
que nos hacen sentir,
que es lo más importante.
Nos hacen pensar, nos hacen ver el mundo
desde otra perspectiva,
y nos ayudan a navegar en el mundo actual,
en el mundo del ahora.
Como diría Benito Taibo,
que es un escritor a quien quiero mucho,
los libros juveniles nos dan
educación emocional,
que es la clase de educación
que todo ser humano debe tener
para sentirse vivo.
Si con algo quiero que se queden
de esta charla, es que los libros,
sin importar el género
o la categoría, son magia.
Los libros son casa,
son amigos, son aventuras.
Y ya basta de menospreciar
a la literatura juvenil.
Basta de subestimar a los jóvenes,
y lo que los jóvenes están leyendo,
porque la literatura juvenil
tiene libros importantísimos
y que están cambiando el mundo
ahora mismo, ya lo están haciendo.
Y si no me creen a mí, pregúntenle
a uno de los millones de jóvenes
cuyo mundo ya ha sido cambiado
por una de estas historias.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)